[Music]
hello everyone and thanks organization
for giving me the chance to give this
talk here and the last she says calm
fishing in this type or whatever so it's
really a pleasure and an honor to be
here in this great conference so the
title of my talk is improving website
performance with CSS containment so
quite a long title even doesn't fit on
this life so I will go over it slowly
so first let's explain a little bit
about me I'm Manuel Drago I'm part of
the Gollywood platform team galius an
aperture consultancy that has a
cooperative like structure so we have
people all around the globe
despite the headquarter starting spring
and we have a large team working on
browsers and we having employment in
several cities the specifications and
other things on some browsers I have
been working a lot mostly for several
years and also the respects in blinkin
work it and now I'm working also in the
CSS containment and as part of all these
work having interacting more and more
with the CSS working group people
putting issues participating discussing
and finally during it the group like two
years ago
so yeah the spec I mean the talk is
about CSS containment this is a CSS spec
this spec has a property that is called
thing and it has four values layout
paint size and style and that's also we
are almost done I mean it's very simple
in theory but I think is going to be
tricky just playing maybe to watch so my
thoughts about will let you out or read
some of my blog post about it I mean it
has tons of properties many different
values for each of them and all that but
I believe it's easier to understand that
maybe CS container so we'll see if I
manage to the properly and you don't get
very bored
so the other part of the title was
improving website performance so
basically you can improve the
performance of a voice in many different
parts you can improve how we much as
load it or the resources or whatever in
this case it's more about the rendering
pipeline these are some ground somehow
the main faces from a very nice article
by Linda Clark so you have like where
you compute the style you do the layout
where you are positioning the scene then
you paint and did you compose I'd the
larger and basically with you're
condemning we are going to be able to
get performance benefits in this in this
pipeline so let's go to this back the
spec is now candidate recommendation so
it's quite a stable at this stage and we
will explain how how it works and try to
explain the different options and all
that so basically the main goal of CSS
containment is to improve the
performance of a website by then define
the independence part of our website
which are part of the Dom tree that
doesn't have to interact with the rest
so somehow it's lighting is a lighting
dust that's that subtree from the rest
of the page in a way that if you do
modifications inside that subtree they
don't get propagated or provided the off
side so you don't need to do work in the
ancestors and all that one confusing
thing about containment when you first
read about it or hear about it is that
the is not that you think subside cannot
affect the elements inside is not top to
bottom what is the other way around
since inside that element are not going
to affect anything outside so this is a
sentence by the back in one of the
speculators that usually needs to repeat
over a hovering the CSS working group
meetings I contain properties or some
block things going into the subtree drop
seems leaking out
so it's quite relevant for all the
containment stuff so yeah I already say
that this is pecan introduce a new
property which name is contained so it's
very easy to remember and this property
has four values main values or types of
containments without pain size style
just put put to combine or combine the
four you can do whatever you want there
in style is writing the slides because
it's market as other is now in the spec
so we will talk more later about that
so imagine this is a website you have
some content some tags harder whatever
and do you know that you have a
component maybe in the top left corner
for example that you are showing some
life information that you are getting or
showing animation or whatever but you
know that's totally independent from the
rest of the page so you identify that
part market like a container element and
when the browser does work there it
doesn't need to care about the rest of
the pages the page is very big or very
complex Dom tree or wherever the browser
doesn't need to spend any single time in
doing all the other stuff so basically
what we've Alfred will need to do is to
identify which are that independent
parts of our website and marketing with
a contain property and then the browser
engine is to do something because it's
not just part of the property and
implement the restrictions but also it
needs to implement some optimizations
and avoid doing extra work browser
engines usually try to do as less work
as possible when you do a change in a
website they have some kind of kind of
heuristics in order to achieve that but
still there are many corner cases and
many combinations on fear so when you do
are changing on a single element that
you belief is not going to affect
anything else the browser is still needs
to maybe check all the siblings just
engage your overflowing content and you
need to paint something in other parts
of whatever and when you use containment
you need you have some kind of
restrictions or implications of using it
so you type you cannot just put
contained to all the elements and you
are done
you need to to put it when it makes
sense so there are like this for type of
containers we are going to review first
one for example module containment
basically here that means that the
internal logic out of the isolated
subtree is totally isolated from the
rest of the of the tree so the
where you put contained large out there
lot out of that element is totally
independent of the of the ancestor so
this is these are the effects it takes
to element any workflow on their
elements treated as in cover flow like
shadows for example like we showing an
example later that element becomes a
containing block for absolute and fifth
position and descendants it also creates
a new stacking context and independent
formating context like display a flow
route and also that the element has no
baseline so why this a restriction when
you use it so let's so an example of
this in Cover Flow thing we have here -
L - dibs at one has contained on the
other container out is the magenta
dotted border the element that has the
container contain laid out so if the
size of the tips is changes here you see
that an August clock scroller is
happening on the parent element so the
browser something changes in size and
needs to do work outside like paint in
the scrollbar but we contain large out
it doesn't need to do anything else I
this is treated as income a sink
overflow like shadows you can attack
this attack Tony but I mean the browser
can avoid doing any work in the parlance
checking if there are overflow and it
needs to print to show a scroller like
here similar is for baseline I say that
when you use like our containment the
element is considered to have no
baseline so basically is the same if the
here in the contain no do you see that
the foo is aligned with the bar in the
other one if use the sink that is a
baseline that there's about the
underlying in this case is the size
change inside the browser needs to move
foo a little bit below however with
contain large out something change
inside but the browser doesn't care I
mean it can save time and avoid that
kind of operation so another type of
containing is pain containment which is
pretty similar to overflow:hidden but
also has some effects so basically the
descendants cannot be displayed outside
of the bond
of the other element but again has
someone first come to circlip like it
with overflow heating but also it
weakens the containing block for for
position at the standard children it
also feels the stacking content and
independent formating context so let's
let's see another example so we have
contained on again in the dotted magenta
element and condemn paint and we have an
absolute position at the element that
fast means 100 pixels top dollar left it
has 200 pixels by 200 pixel size so it's
position it against the parent meeting
it's the view per whatever I mean the
other case is position it again the
container element is moving a little bit
left left on top and also the
overflowing things are cleared so when
you change the color here the browser
needs to paint also things outside that
element but here the rostral needs to
paint paintings inside so again if you
have an element with content painting
that is not in the viewport the browser
can avoid doing work on it doing doing
any payment painting because the roles
are you sure that there are if not
something overflow in that that is
painted in the viewport whatever they
know that they can say that the time
size containment it's about how the
brochure computes the size of an element
basically if you put contain size is
going to ignore the children so the
element is treated as having no contents
only things like parting at other space
or : rapid you have multi column or the
tracks in grid something like that you
already define but not the contents
itself and also it's monolithic that
means that you cannot split it when you
print it or it's in multi column or
things like that so again this is the
same example again so the first element
the size depends on the content is hello
world and when the contest changed the
size change but in this case only is the
body in the size
defining the the size of that element if
the contents changed it doesn't care you
see that it's about flowing the thing is
that when you combine this with the
other ones the roster can say okay I'm
sure know for sure that nothing is going
to change your side even the size isn't
going to affect anything outside and all
that and then last one its stem
containment this is somehow special
because it only affects counters and
quotes I don't know if you use them a
lot I guess no because it's not very
common but and this is on the spec and
it's currently Marcos market as a trace
because the scope is maybe too narrow
only counter sanghas unquote so there
are some discussions about if it's worth
five foot for example is not
implementing this so far so that's
another reason why is weights at risk in
the spec because they don't see the
benefit and also chroming implementation
of containing a style containment is
pretty broken so only works for the very
simple cases so if any of you find that
use case that it can get performance
benefit with stake containment shell
with a CSS working group and the github
repository because that will be valuable
information to know if we need to keep
or not this value so basically the facts
are that the counters and quotes at the
scope to the subtree and that when you
try to increment a counter you actually
are creating a new one instead of
incrementing it so basically the same
example with counters this is a class
that is incrementing this counter and
and this is just an element that paints
the counter so we are here creating this
content and increment into one then we
print it is as well then we have a
container style element so this content
inside cannot increment the one outside
so it creates a new one so we have here
one dot well and when we print it after
all size of the container element this
doesn't know anything of what happening
inside with the counter so that's what
she so late effects still growing again
so that will be the expected output
then with close quotes are acting giving
a less common use case so you can define
what with which symbols are you using
when you have nested Khujo so this is
doable first and then single or whatever
and then we are opening a quote here we
have full then we have the style
containment element and we open another
quote we have the text bar and then we
close the quote when we close this it
doesn't know that a new one was opening
inside the style containment element so
it just closed a initial the opening we
are not closing both in this case but
they mean basically that the changes
here doesn't affect anything outside so
okay we have Alice using the spec so you
can say contain content and that implies
logout and paint or you can say contain
a strict and that implies like out paint
and size this used include style to are
like a stylish market at risk and
Firefox was planning to ship CSS
containment it was removed from the spec
at this stage if in the future a stylus
is implemented by all the browser's
probably there will be a new alias like
all or whatever that will include the
style so let's just the state to sort of
of things this is not a new aspect maybe
it's the first time you've heard about
it but if that's been shipping for three
years already in chromium so it's not an
us back at all and Google has been using
it in their products like YouTube or
Gmail giving in the chrome dev tools
inside that but in past year there has
been quite a quirk quite a lot of work
in the in despair
Florian reoww reoww one of the spec
editors has been working quite a lot I'm
pushing this peg to candy the
recommendation also that is sweet in web
platform that repository has been
completed by the altar port and with
contributors from Mozilla and chromium
like why we were working in the
presentations we at the Galea having
decent implementation in chromium so
it's aligned with the spec and we can
start implement of demonstration based
on that
and that was causing us to roll all the
to be breaking most of the sides I mean
we broke due to for our Hajime we broke
the tool several times because maybe
they were using contain like out for
example in many places and now the
overflow is tilted a sink overflow so
you can attack to see if you like that
or now that is a containing block for
the position of the stand and so
everything is proceeding it were only so
you need to or stop using contain logout
or change how things are go work inside
that element and then Firefox is also
working on implementation they are
targeting Firefox 69 to really to ship
it but you can already test it we found
the runtime flag and me and welcoming
has been implementing some optimizations
based on CSS content so like I say you
can just parse the property in the
browser implement the restrictions and
you are bypassing all the tests of CSS
containment so you are totally spec on
client but they didn't have any
optimization in the browser free is not
useful at all for there at the end so
then when the erosion has that
information it needs to still implement
some optimizations and if we look at can
I use like Microsoft is moving to
chromium link it's getting support for
this all the chromium process has
support for this and Firefox is about to
shift in a few releases and then regard
in Safari were key there are no public
signals yet so let's so some examples to
try to understand this a little bit
better this is one example from a blog
post I published about containment is
very simple and not cool at all but I
believe it's the best want to understand
how how it works so imagine that we have
a very Dom tree like ten thousand
elements like this item that has all of
them has have one one children one child
and we are modifying the content of that
child over and over or whatever so we
have a Dom tree like this we have many
many elements here but we are only doing
changes in this pudding
deep but still the rotor needs to do
working the rest not not out of warm any
maybe just rubber and traversing the
fallen tree to do some checks or
whatever but he's doing work another
thing so we can say okay this has
container strip we don't I mean we
cannot affect anything outside we are
just changing since I hear the brochure
can avoid navigating the rest of the
things so this example is an ocular doll
is changing the the text in the first
element I need that dolly goes from
singing it is taking six milliseconds
without containment to take 0.2
milliseconds with container strict so
it's like a quite a bit difference this
is another example is the same one but
I'm using real adult in the items
because I know that real adult has all
this truck sizing algorithm so it's
somehow costly if we think about
performance so it takes a while and on
the Left we have chromium on the right
we have Firefox that's because I was
crafting this example for this talk and
I realize it we are not we were not
getting very good resource in chromium
so he was check it Firefox and rifle was
much better and it makes actually sends
the results we are getting five for
example with these 10,000 items in
chroming is like 12 times faster with
container Street please quite a lot but
in five forces like 2700 faster but that
makes sense because if you need to visit
10,000 grid containers and do large out
on will on each of them and all that
whatever you need to do instead of just
doing eating one it's suspected that
it's very very fast when you just have
this streak containment in the relevant
that you just do it there so we have
been working on this at regalia as part
of our ongoing collaboration with
Bloomberg in which we implemented CSS
will lag out in the past year or we
having implementing this in JavaScript
like a sink away tour begin like lately
and bloomer has some quite complex you
guys and then we're getting benefit
efficiency SS containment in some of
them so this is one of the stress cases
we had this is like a huge table table
like logout or will it like like they
out it doesn't have to be a table or
agreed it doesn't matter when it's at
like ten thousand cells or whatever and
the text is changing constantly but we
actually know that we are just changing
one number by another one day by another
another number that the number is going
to fit in the size we are providing we
know that for sure so we don't need we
can say the roster okay this element has
contain larger size and you can avoid
doing the layout of the details you are
changing there because if you are adding
a long sentence or whatever the browser
needs to do line breaking all that and
calculate some things so we are saying
okay you can say for that time if we
have contain layout size because we know
that we are just changing one number way
another and it's going to fit inside and
then this is stress test with ten
thousand eleven we were like four times
faster using containment so it's nice of
demonization this is the still to report
to let out India which is anything that
chromium is shipping really soon so it
will be like similar similar things this
was another one pretty similar again
very big table or whatever here are some
of the progress bars are moving are
changing size you were changing the
contest like that but something is
changing size inside each of them but
the thing is that in the use case each
of these cells were absolute position
air so we have like each of them has its
own layer
so the browser when something was
changing is higuaín it was traversing
the whole layer three in depending on
the size of the wrong in that was taking
a while in some faces and then we
contain a strict and a very big stress
that we get like them percent faster
it's not a lot but it is seeming
everything it helps prolly we were
respecting more but maybe they are room
for
more things yet so let's take talk about
the future of all these we can expect
better browser support Firefox is cheap
in really soon we don't know Safari but
we hope that they mean we never heard
complaints from Apple about this respect
so it seems maybe at some point they
will they will have it other thing that
we can expect it's more optimization
based on CSS contain basically when
people are start to use it they will say
okay like this example I just did in
chromium ok this will be much faster
than what we are seeing I mean I'm
changing just one element it will be
almost as fast as having just one
element in the Dom despite I have a ton
of 10,000 elements or whatever so you
can report a bath and probably the
browser will try to improve that use
case with some optimization because
maybe I mean this is how it's not new
because it has been there for a while
but there has not being a lot of work so
there are still a lot of room for
improvement here in a lot of 50 massages
to belong the in the browser and also
there are some new features that were
proposed as there are that some
brochures are working on their
application on this spec so I don't know
if you have heard about this play
locking proposal from Google Google is
experimenting with this and have some
experimental implementation already in
chrome you bring idea of discipline
locking is that in a don't read you can
lock an element of the tongue then you
do manipulation in JavaScript you modify
whatever you need there without blocking
the main thread and then when everything
is really you unlock it and show it in
the screen but for that you need that
the element element is independent of
the rest and that's where containment
came to the rescue and I mean you mark
that element with contain and then you
can do that so seems like it will I mean
like in the future will will appear
maybe display login it's not the the
feature that is finally standardized but
this one of of these of these ideas and
that's all from my side I hope you
understand a little bit better now what
this is pack is about you can start
experimenting with it and report buffs
about it
in my blog you can read I mean I just
only have one article about this but
maybe in the future I will have more
they have me writing articles about it
and we are working on for a while and I
will be around the whole day feel free
to talk to me about CSS containments
users worried how it takes to implement
CSS affecting a brochure or things like
that or even ask me about ugali and the
things we do so that's all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]